going from playing a great soldier in
Game of Thrones to a great God and
Asgardian god what's it like playing a
god on the big screen it's very odd
getting your head around the idea that
you're playing a god that's that's for
sure one and also the the sets and the
filming experiences studio in Belfast is
pretty extraordinary they're pretty big
sets and we're in this huge hall here
and the sets for Thor would this height
you walk in and I'm six with six and I
feel tiny and also you're filming
against blue-screen or green-screen so
the experience of filming it's oddly
it's odd and there's a different kind of
filming it's not a lot of scenes about
personal relationships and it's an
action movie in a certain way it's a
genre movie which is extraordinarily
spectacular it's a very different genre
Game of Thrones is is a kind of fantasy
and yet it's not it's very real you
really believe it
the other one is something else in Thor
2 I mean I'm guessing that means you
have kind of action scenes you wielding
one of the iconic weapons like the mace
in that at all I'm not at liberty to say
but yes I do have a I do have a bit of a
fight in it and it's clear that I'm a
person who's probably used to looking
after themselves
it's another violent world on an epic
scale you venture Nancy Hopkins oh
what's it like working with this
co-stars Tom Hiddleston as Loki we've
got Chris Hemsworth as Thor of course
but those guys like to work with Rainey
Russo's in it yeah Natalie Portman it's
very interesting
you find it those moments see what you
are a punter you know watching this
watch and see how he does it and
certainly Hopkins along with the
American actors one of the things you're
always you're constantly amazed by is
how little they do there's a different
tradition amongst British actors because
basically we come from theater I work
with Benicio del Toro on a scene in
which it was meant to be quite angry and
sitting 15 feet away I couldn't hear
what he was saying but you look on the
screen and it's absolutely there we
turned to Blair and shoutin and gern and
overact the Americans he grew up with
film and have a an experience and
respect for that is different from ours
that really know how to nail it I think
it's a great car so I was so looking
forward to seeing I mean what would your
reaction be if we did lose Loki in this
movie Tommy the sons character
pleasure this is a Charles dance moment
you